THE LEAD, 13 FOR ON THE OTHER
END. TALKING ABOUT
TALLHE HAD
POSSESSION, BUT STILL A CALL
HERE IN .
EUBANKS, TRYING TO PICK UP
ACHIEVE ONE THERE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE SAW FOR
THREE JOEL EMBIID.
IT IFADING
THE LEAD
>> Alaa: WE SAY AT THE
HE IS FEELING IT TONIGHT.
>> Alaa: EUBANKS AIN'T READY
FOR IT .  HE'S SOLUTELY TWO-
POSSESSION GAME
20 POINTS TO LEAD NOT HAVESTUDI
CONTINUATION ON THAT?
>>THEIR
LAST 23, THEY ARE 3 OF BOTH,
OFFENSIVE.
PLUMLEE MATISSEING OTHERS INVOL
AS WELL.
EVERYONE GETTING ON.
>> NOT EASY TO DO SHOWING , J
LEADING THE CHARGE, THE DOUBLE-
THEN HE WILL K K THET YOU
>> THEY ARE YOUNG GUYS.OF
COURSE, THAT NICE TOUCH THERE
AS WELLROW, YOU KNOW YOU
ARE PLAYING A TEAM YOU CRUSHED
A WE
REALLY GOOD.
YOU CAN
SEE THE PROGRESSION IN HE E WHI
WON IN  WA
THIRD QUARTER.
JOEL, OFF THE BACK , DIRECTING
TRAFFIC.
ATTACKING THE RIM.
MAXEY.
NOW MELO.
DOUBLE FROM
OVER, AND JOEL GETS HIS WAYLAND
THE HEAT TONIGHT.
>> KatSTARTING TO REALLY
CR
EA
TE